The jogan Experience hey we're no
different yeah World War II now we've
been chilling for a while and all of a
sudden there's some well how long do we
chill for it up to Vietnam we
that barely
counts what compared to World War II
right but completely unnecessary whereas
World War I was necessary because of an
unnecessary start what was the
unnecessary start of World War II
Hitler taken everything yeah but like it
a lot of it is based on what happened
World War I right yes so World War I one
and two are pretty there everything in
history is interlined and there's not
that much time between them either so
there's like a regrouping of Germany and
now we'll [__] show you yeah
yeah uh what was World War I over that's
the ultimate dumbest [__] one ever
what is it over uh austri Arch Duke
France Ferd got assassinated in Serbia
that's right and then the guy lucky ran
into him outside of a restaurant yeah I
tried to kill him didn't then his car
was parked outside of a restaurant he's
like oh yeah there he is there he is
yeah and then uh their Ally was Serbia's
Ally was Russia Austria's Ally was
Germany Germany was like we're going to
help
Austria that's why they got
blamed wow and then the whole world and
the whole world which they were all
cousins why were they why they
assassinate that dude uh because Austria
and Serbia I guess had a pretty long
history of fighting each other and he
was in
Serbia monegro was it and he it was kind
of like flaunting it a little was kind
of like you shouldn't be here Nancy
Pelosi went to Tai Juan yeah yeah yeah
yeah of just like yeah I can handle it
yeah what what you gonna do CH I could
be wrong though I think it was like uh
France Ferdinand was actually like one
of the guys in Austria that liked Serbia
and he was one of the guys like helping
it he was like a advocate for it and
then uh the blackand and I'm forgetting
his [__] name he's very important the
guy who shot him I don't remember his
name either it's embarrassing I don't
remember it and I hope it's Seria I just
I'm talking I think it is he was from
the kingdom of Serbia this isn't the
thing I was looking at didn't have his
name
H this doesn't either so what happens to
Germany during World War I so World War
I was over nothing they fought everybody
died like millions of people died over
and a lot of times it's just trench
warfare where they over the course of
four or five years they gained nothing
lost nothing so at the end of the war
like when France and Germany and England
had to sign this treaty they were like
like the Allies that won were like oh we
got to make we got to gain something out
of this because otherwise our people are
going to kill us when we signed this
treaty and neither of us nothing changed
and that was all for literally for
nothing so then they they just blamed
Germany for everything they were like
you guys you owe France
reparations gabilla prinet got him so
good he was 19 years old [__] up the
whole world wow good job Gilla one
teenager yeah you imagine imagine being
one person
and so many things happen because of one
thing that you do a 19-year-old yeah
like imagine being the CEO Bud
Light imagine being that lady it's not
the CEO right what was she like
marketing yeah that was just marke
imagine being that
lady up in the
middle [__] yeah I would yeah I don't
know how comparable that is to Gilla
prin in the business world business
world that was World War I it's World
War I yeah yeah they didn't know they
didn't know the capabilities of the
weapons right just like yeah nobody had
figured out gas world one was doing
nobody figured out Kid Rock shooting
your product they were
doing they were doing Cavalry Charges
into machine guns that other picture of
me look pretty handsome go to that
picture imagine that guy shoots you
you're like [__] [__] guy great
cheekbones you ever see young Stalin he
looks like uh Scott Eastwood young
Stalin was a babe was he yeah
criminal penalty 20 years imprisonment
you died three years later di wow that
[__] started it all off damn he
was he was alive though for three years
to witness what he did that's a tough
way yeah wonder if he connected the mall
clearly he had yeah clearly that started
it yeah I bet it was a lot of bragging
in the showers you know when I did
[__] killed everyone I got
everybody
killed one of my favorite stories from
World War I that I've talked about too
much is that the Russians and the
Germans had a ceasefire to kill wolves
that's awesome yeah they I didn't know
about that they were in Russia and so
many of them were getting killed by
wolves that they decided to have a
ceasefire they they negotiated a
ceasefire to kill
wolves cuz terrifying imagine if you're
a trench warfare and you get shot and
you're screaming and you're in agony and
then dog
eat and there's 30 wolves tearing your
friend apart and there's nothing you can
do you jump up people shoot you yeah
that's uh and then the Wolves just get
into The Trenches World one seems like
the worst bro seems like one of the look
at what the worst dressed like how do
they survive the elements I don't know
they had stupid shoes they didn't their
shoes were so stupid they had like shoes
that you would wear if you're like
walking down the street yeah and they're
out in the woods they're in the mud for
months at a time yeah what show us what
they were dressed like their boots were
stupid like everything was stupid
there's no no waterproofing there's no
nothing there's no tactical gear yeah
had nothing you had [__] Cotton
shirts that's what Hitler Hitler did to
his boys the guys that went into Russia
he was like we're going to be done by we
don't even need to make winter uniforms
for these
guys with leather sold shoes they didn't
even have like textured shoe SS back
then this guy's having fun just a good
time trench warfare it ain't nothing but
a [__] Christ man imagine imagine
that life that dude is taking a nap
there just living in hell they got some
cool art that came out of this from
these guys getting [__] up you ever
see auto auto dicks no get some Auto
dicks go back to that photo again please
that photo you just had of those
guys wow are these are these Dough Boys
what are these americ these are
Americans look at their little [__]
outfits imagine being stuck over there
going what the [__] are we here for gas
Mas on their neck right yep yep that's
when they first started using
gas [__]
man what a horrific time have you seen
All Quiet on the Western Front yes I I
love it oh no wait a minute I haven't no
that's the new one right yes you got to
watch that no I haven't you got to watch
that it's so good you told me about it
multiple I love it I get bummed out when
I watch war movies it's the most
depressing one I've seen in a while yeah
[__] I always say I'm going to do it
when I'm like sitting in front of the TV
but when I'm sitting in front of the TV
most of the time I just like to be
entertained I just just show me I want
to watch got to watch that one I get
really depressed it's bad dude I get
anxiety sometimes in the middle of the
night when everyone's asleep again
anxiety thinking about the wars yeah AO
dicks has some good ones artists dicks
got he got [__] up from that war and
this is all his work oh my God
everybody's all bullet hold and patched
together oh wow so he was a soldier yeah
I think he yeah he's German oh my god
dude these are
horrific yeah what did that guy see oh
you ever see all right this I don't know
how good this is for podcasting but you
got to look at Goya oh look at Goya look
at his
uh have we ever talked about this on the
gas mask are crazy gas mask are scary
cuz that's the first time they ever
experienced gas attacks
Goya that was actually the those are the
Napoleonic Wars he was a Spanish guy God
look at all those B but then he got dark
dude he got into some scary stuff some
Satan [__] yeah allegedly his last
paintings were who so they're called the
black paintings bro can you imagine
being a the first time they start using
gas no that would be a b like they just
got giant fans and they're spraying
deadly gas towards you oh God look at
his stuff man oh my God
that's yeah it says it is Francisco Goya
no he did Saturn Dev Saturn Sun Painting
oh God look at that that's horrifying
he's eating a baby he did s uh Saturn
devouring his son well I think that's
what's happening right there that's not
the real one different one yeah that's
the one oh God oh my God Jamie go to
that one in the the bigger one in the
left hand corner right leftand corner of
of that like keep going no no no no back
hold on I want to lose it the one below
it to the left that's it that go to that
one right there look at that that's so
horrifying man yeah Goya has some eating
a baby what the [__]
man and that's like a valuable painting
like someone could have that in their
home oh this is a Goya it's worth five
no that painting billion dollars yeah
how much is that worth that
Goya did you say it's called the
official name like death Saturn
devouring his son lot of Satan Satanist
money out there I think that was in
uh what's that movie uh about greed is
good what's that called Wall Street Wall
Street Wall Street
easiest orinal Wall Street wolf walls
the orinal one GRE is Wall Street I
think he had that in his office my
favorite scene in that movie is Michael
Douglas walking down the beach with that
brick phone like he was a pimp those
brick phones were the [__] back then oh
my God he's talking to someone it says
his most valuable work was sold for 7.5
and that one would be much more valuable
wow it's more valuable why don't they
sell it maybe they don't want got it
never imagine wanting that in your house
I've I have some goas do you yeah for
real yeah I got the he go talking
and prince prince yeah I'm like what you
yeah 48 million worth of movie to ke's
money uh I saw those there's a museum I
forget it was Sophia Raina maybe in
Madrid and I was at it and they have
what's called his dark paintings or
black paintings I forget but apparently
Goya lost his mind and all these
paintings were from in his own house on
the walls like that was painted that
wasn't on a canvas that was on his wall
that he did by himself he lost his mind
he would paint at night with candles on
his head oh my like a chandelier of
candles on his head painted satanic [__]
now that's I think they've said that
this was a legend but I'm not sure whoa
I want to believe it it's awesome you
see those paintings you're like holy
it's like it seems like ay goat talking
to witches you're like holy sh a guy
eating a baby yeah yeah pretty cool that
seems like something someone who would
have a [__]
candle Chandelier on their head sounds
he was 72 when he moved into the house
some guy took all hacked quotes hacked
off all of the murals from the wall and
attached them to Canvas and they're now
on that museum yeah wow and he sought
him off the wall he was he saw that'd be
even more valuable yeah it's pretty
awesome chunk of his wall too imagine
walking into that
house bro what was going on one the
greatest artist mind well saw the he saw
like War Horrors yeah he saw [__] up
War the most close combat bullet type
War you could get into trench warfare no
no this this is Napoleonic Wars oh
that's right this is old Spain where he
swords and [__] Cannon and like
atrocities